Let's review what
we've done this week.
We've seen that the work done
by a force along a trajectory
from point A to point
B can be written
as the integral of the
dot product of that force,
with the displacement
going from point A
to point B, where we note that
this integral, in general,
must be evaluated over
the particular path taken
from point A to point
B. This is called a line
integral or a path integral.
And again, I want to
emphasize the value
of this integral depends, in
general, on the path taken
from point A to point B.
And you could understand
that if you considered the fact
that, in general, the force is
a function of position.
And so if you go
along different paths,
the dot product of the
force with a particular path
may be different, even
though you're going
between the same end points.
Now, the reason that the
work is a useful concept
is that it allows
us to understand
how the kinetic energy of an
object-- so the kinetic energy
is 1/2mv squared.
The work allows us to understand
how the kinetic energy evolves
under the action of a force.
And we see that through what's
called the work-kinetic energy
theorem, which states that
the work done-- so again,
the integral of F
dot ds from point A
to point B, evaluated
along the specific path--
is equal to the change
in the kinetic energy.
So that's 1/2mvB
squared, since B
is the final point,
minus 1/2mvA squared,
where A is the initial point.
And this is equal to the
change in the kinetic energy.
And we derived this theorem
from Newton's second law,
F equals ma.
So this is essentially
just a restatement
of Newton's second law.
Now, two things to note
about the work and this work
integral-- the first is that the
work integral, when evaluated,
it just gives a number, because
a dot product is a scalar.
And that number can be
either positive, or negative,
or even zero, depending upon
whether the velocity increases,
decreases, or stays the same
under the action of the force,
as you go from
point A to point B.
The second point to
emphasize is that, again,
this integral, in
general, must be evaluated
along the specific
path taken from point A
to point B, which means that in
order to evaluate the integral,
we need to know
what that path is.
Now, if we have a situation
where we don't know in advance
what the path is, then we
can't evaluate the integral.
So in a way, it might seem
like a not very useful concept,
that we haven't
really made progress,
because we need to know
the answer about what
the trajectory is before we
can calculate the work done.
And it's not clear
why that's useful.
However, what I
want to point out
is that there are two
special cases that
are particularly useful.
The first special case is
that of constrained motion.
Sometimes we know in advance
what the path is going to be,
because the motion
is constrained.
We know that it's going
to be moving along--
the object is going to be
moving along a circular path
or along some particular track
of some particular shape.
And as long as we can
describe that trajectory,
we can evaluate our work
integral along that trajectory.
So that's a case where
even though the work is
a path-dependent integral,
we know the path,
and so we can
evaluate the integral.
The second special
case we've seen
is that there is a
special class of forces
called conservative forces.
And conservative forces have the
property that the work integral
is independent of the path.
So for a conservative force,
to work integral only depends
upon the endpoints A and
B, and not upon the path
you take to get from A
to B. So for any path,
you'll always get the same
value of the work integral
if the force is conservative.
OK, so those are the
two cases in which
we can usefully apply work
and the work-energy theorem.
Now in general, one
might have a combination
of conservative and
non-conservative forces
acting on a system.
And in that case,
we can actually
write the work as consisting
of two separate terms.
The work done by conservative
forces, what I'll write as Wc,
plus the work done by the
non-conservative forces, Wnc.
And so the conservative
work is just
the work integral evaluated
for the conservative forces,
so Fc, for conservative force,
dot ds, going from A to B.
And because this
force is conservative,
this integral is
path independent.
Let me emphasize that here.
This is a
path-independent integral.
It's not a line integral.
It only depends
upon the endpoints,
because the force
is conservative.
The second term is the
non-conservative work.
And that is the work done by the
non-conservative force, F sub
mc, dotted with ds, between
the same end points, A and B.
But this integral does depend
upon the specific path.
The path matters for this
term, because there the force
is non-conservatives.
So in general, you
can compute the work
by separating out the
conservative force
and the non-conservative
force acting on the system,
if both are acting.
If the force is
only conservative,
then you only have
to worry about
the path-independent
integral, which in general is
much simpler to evaluate.
If the force is
non-conservative,
then you need to specify
the path in order
to evaluate the integral.
Again, a path-dependent
integral is often
called a path integral
or a line integral.